-Guys, I heard that the TV
ratings for Trump's rallies
have gone down.
People are saying his rallies
are like "Pirates of
the Caribbean" movies.
They're wild and new at first,
then you realize
they're all exactly the same.
Anyway...
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Boring.
But the midterm elections
are under a month away,
and Trump's campaign is
selling football jerseys
that say "Stand Up for America."
Yeah, the outside says,
"Stand Up for America,"
while the inside says,
"Made in China."
-Really?
[ Applause ]
-Check this out.
I heard that Trump
keeps a printed list
of his accomplishments
that he shows to reporters
to get them to write
positive things about him.
He does.
It has 58 bullet points,
and we actually
got our hands on it.
Take a look at this.
-Appointed two
Supreme Court justices.
Increased military spending.
Lowered taxes for millionaires.
Fired Michael Flynn.
Fired Sally Yates.
Fired James Comey.
Fired Reince Priebus.
Fired Steve Bannon.
Fired Rex Tillerson.
Fired David Shulkin.
Hired Anthony Scaramucci.
Fired Anthony Scaramucci.
Fired H.R. McMaster.
Fired Andrew McCabe.
Fired Omarosa.
-All right. I got it. I got it.
I got it. I got it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
He hired Scaramucci.
-Yeah, then he fired him.
-Oh, this week, former New York
Mayor Mike Bloomberg
switched his voter registration
and became a Democrat.
[ Light applause ]
When asked him
what made him change parties,
Bloomberg said, "Kanye."
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of New York, there's
a hospital here in the city
that keeps a Spotify playlist
full of songs
with beats that match up
with CPR compressions.
'Cause when you're having
a heart attack,
who doesn't want to hear
their doctor say,
"So what do you think,
Drake or Migos?
Sorry, we weren't
talking about you.
Oops, I put on...
Sorry, you're dead."
Get this -- a cheating scandal
has rocked the world
of wine tasting.
-What?!
-Please, don't leave the room.
This is a true --
That's right. It's rocked
the world of wine tasting.
A cheating scandal came out
that some tasters
were given the answers
to an exam.
The wine tasters say
that they are embarrassed,
a little humiliated,
and there's a hint of shame.
[ Laughter, applause ]
Long walk.
-Long walk.
-It was worth it when
we got there, wasn't it?
Come on.
[ Laughter ]
The longest joke of the night.
Yeah.
Little taste of shame there.
-Ooh, shame.
-Yeah.
You guys, the news
is so crazy lately,
sometimes it almost
feels like someone
blended a bunch of
stories together.
So we thought, what if we
took some real headlines
and blended them together?
Would the news stories be any
crazier than the actual news?
Let's find out.
If you blend the stories "Kanye
and Kid Rock Reveal Music Bill,"
"'Time' Honors
23andMe DNA Test,"
and "Funky White Sister
Surprised to Attend AMAs,"
you get "Surprise --
DNA Test Reveals
Kid Rock is Kanye's
Funky White Sister."
You see what I'm saying?
-Yeah, that's just crazy.
-A little bit crazier than --
-Just a tiny bit.
-Next up,
if you blend the stories
"Celebrity Couple
Gets Matching Tattoos,"
"Nicki Minaj Faces Lawsuit,"
and "Very High Ticket Prices
for Bill and Hillary Clinton's
Tour,"
you get "Very High
Bill and Hillary Clinton
Get Matching Face Tattoos
of Nicki Minaj."
[ Applause ]
Here's the last one.
If you blend the stories
"Yellowstone Geyser
Erupts Trash,"
"Stock Market Down,
Trump Reacts,"
and "Natty Light Selling
77-Can Pack,"
you get "Trump Down 77 Pack
of Natty Light,
Erupts Yellow Geyser
in Trash Can."
You see what I'm saying?
-A little bit.